we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using 45
percent less water but with a stream of
water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com slash david
pakman
today i'm starting with a correction
last week in discussing
a white house press secretary kaylee
mcinanny's claim
that the odds of what happened in terms
of the vote in four different states
were one in one quadrillion she also
said
the odds of that happening in four
states
is one in one quadrillion raised to the
fourth power
i with no explanation said that's not
how exponents work
that was very unclear and really
inaccurate in the context in which i
said it
if one and one quadrillion were the
right numbers at the state level
raising it to the fourth power would
give us the combined probability
in theory that is how exponents work by
not explaining
i may have not been clear and i
apologize for that
i will try to do better in the future uh
let's get on to the week's news
it's a truly a tragedy what's going on
in this country
in general but i'm talking right now
about coronavirus
i get that we're a huge country
geographically
we have 330 million people i get that
but we're some of the worst of the worst
in the world
and we are now having a 9 11's worth of
deaths
on one day regularly and the numbers are
potentially going to get
much worse before they get any better
now i know many people on the right
including donald trump like to say well
everyone is seeing the same thing
that could not be further from the truth
and i want to examine that with you
today because we really need to
understand
just how terribly we are doing the claim
is everyone's seeing the same thing
cases are spiking here
cases are spiking there italy's you know
sweden whatever
uh that's mostly based on this
spike in mid-october that we started
seeing just like many other
european countries but there are two
really important differences to
understand here the first is that when
the u.s
started seeing its october spike
that was already our third spike because
we had spike number one in april and
spike number two in july so
middle of october we're on spike number
three
that's a key difference because in italy
for example
their mid-october spike was only their
second spike in other words
italy successfully suppressed the virus
throughout
may june july august september early
october
so when we were entering spike three and
they were also spiking they were only on
their second spike so that's a huge
difference and that applies to just
about all of these european countries
that did not have the second spike we
had
just as importantly these european
countries that started getting a spike
when we did in mid-october
most of them have already suppressed the
spike and they've seen a decline
from the highs of about 50 percent of
new cases per day so as an example
we look at spain and you see that yes
spain
started having spike number two at the
same time that we started having spike
number three
but their trend line for the seven day
case average is already down by half
from where it peaked
if you look at another example like
france you also see that while they
spiked in mid-october like we did their
cases are already way down
but when you look at the united states
we have this spike that started at the
same time
but we are reaching new records just
about every day this has been one of the
biggest failures of any presidential
administration ever
it's globally shameful but it is a
tragedy in terms of
its its toll on human life and suffering
and it's going to take time to fix this
now there's no way around it and and we
know
that on january 21st every coronavirus
death will be blamed on joe biden by
these republicans
all i care is that we fix it if now they
want to start wearing masks and social
distancing because biden's present
then do it in order to show i don't know
what i don't think that that's going to
be their reaction and of course
it's too late for the 300 000 people
that died already
it's too late for the many that
recovered from serious cases of the
virus
and still have symptoms and unknown
long-term effects
that we don't yet understand the good
news is
the fda has approved an emergency use
authorization
for the pfizer biontech vaccine i've
been saying bioentech but someone told
me it's biontech
that is approved and we're going to talk
about vaccination momentarily
december 17th which is uh what is that
thursday
the fda will be meeting about the
moderna vaccine and we'll have a more
detailed report later in the week about
that
if indeed it is approved and we'll talk
more about vaccines momentarily
but this is a cautionary tale about what
not to do
this is not about taking you know it's
so depressing about
don jr early in this entire fiasco
said oh democrats want people to die to
make trump look bad
no i have not i've not found a single
person on the left or a democrat who
wants people to die
uh what we do want is that those
responsible for the failed leadership be
held accountable in a sense trump was
because he lost the election
but this is really a cautionary tale
about what not to do
and part of what not to do is don't
elect a buffoonish and competent clown
to be president of the united states
let's talk about vaccination
the fda has authorized
the pfizer biontech coronavirus vaccine
they did it on friday night now it came
under a cloud of allegations
that either trump or his chief of staff
mark meadows or someone
called the fda director stephen hahn
and said approve this today and when
stephen hahn was interviewed about that
over the weekend
he didn't deny it he just insisted
everything was done based on the science
and to me that's a pretty clear
non-denial but the point is
we now have an approved vaccine this
same vaccine has been approved in the uk
it has been approved in canada and now
it has been approved here in the united
states
vaccination starts today as far as we
know with high-risk health care workers
believed to be getting top priority in
all 50 states
ultimately states decide how to allocate
and prioritize
the tranches of doses that they will be
receiving we have three million doses
already fanning out across the country
via logistics and shipping companies
over the weekend
145 different sites will be receiving
the vaccine today
another 400 sites tomorrow another 60
something on wednesday
now there is not uh nearly enough supply
even if
now we say we're just doing medical
workers we don't
yet have the supply to inoculate every
doctor nurse
hospital security guard receptionist
phlebotomist other workers
who risk being exposed every single day
we just don't have enough doses yet
because the vaccines can cause side
effects
like fevers and aches for a day or two
hospitals also can't even if they had
all the doses they can't give it to
everybody at once because everybody
might be out sick the next day
obviously it's only a fraction that
actually get the side effects but it's
you have to stagger it in order to avoid
even the possibility of that
so this is going to be a process uh
residents of nursing homes
who have been disproportionately
suffering the death
by coronavirus are also expected to be
top priority
and again this is all based on expected
shipping we're expecting to see
some nursing home residents start to be
vaccinated next week
new york's first coronavirus vaccines
have arrived
and we're expecting vaccinations today
at
long island jewish medical center and
maybe even a couple of other
locations most people's eligibility
based on prioritization is likely to put
them
sometime around spring for being able to
get a vaccine
the new york times reported that the
administration had a plan
to vaccinate all of its own staff
including people that work around trump
even though these first doses are
supposed to go to health care workers
and apparently there was not good
reaction to that donald trump canceling
that by twitter yesterday saying quote
people working in the white house should
receive the vaccine
somewhat later in the program unless
specifically necessary
i have asked that this adjustment be
made i am not scheduled to take the
vaccine but look forward to doing so at
the appropriate time
still we are going to have to deal with
vaccine hesitancy
issues among some and that's raising
questions about whether all available
doses will
even be requested once we get my
expectation is
now with the doses going to health care
workers and still not having enough for
all of them
every dose will be spoken for for now in
the nursing home phase i believe every
dose will be spoken for
once we get a second approved vaccine
modern
more than likely and we see the next
layer which is likely going to be the
oldest folks
if you don't have the demand that you
expect and as of right now
60 percent of the country plans to get
the vaccine
40 percent of the country does not you
could have a situation
where even these early batches of doses
don't get swept up and in that case
there's going to be some real questions
now
you know the the idea would be that over
time
as you start to see oh my kid's school
requires uh
that parents be vaccinated i don't know
if that's possible or eventually if the
vaccines are open for kids
the kid to be vaccinated or if i want to
fly with this airline i have to be
vaccinated if i want to go to a sporting
event i have to be vaccinated that will
probably push the number of people
wanting the vaccine
up from 60. they will call it a
mandatory vaccination of course it won't
be it will be
if you want to partake in a certain
service or business
then you have to choose to go and get a
vaccine it's up to you
ultimately but we could have a situation
where because of
under use of the vaccines
due to lack of interest you're going to
have a situation
where people may well be able to jump
the line and what i mean by that is
if hospitals are giving the vaccines to
their workers they know who qualifies
if nursing homes homes are giving
vaccines to their residents
they know these are our residents once
you get beyond that
from what i've been reading cvs and
walgreens aren't going to
check do you really have diabetes is
that do you actually qualify right now
under the you have to have one or two
comorbidities
and so the opportunity to jump the line
is likely to be a real thing now at the
same time
if not everybody wants the vaccine you
may have doses
left over and i don't know how
it's going to be chaotic to some degree
my approach is going to be
at no point will i act in a way where i
am taking
a vaccine away from someone whose higher
priority
than me who wants it if it becomes clear
that the doses are not actually being
swept up by the people who are next on
the list
and there's an announcement of come and
get one or pay a hundred bucks
and come and get one because we have
doses unclaimed that will go bad
if somebody doesn't get vaccinated i
would absolutely do that but i have no
interest
in jumping the line if it's going to
actually take a vaccine away from
someone who
is up next in terms of the vaccination
protocol that's my mindset
and we're going to take it a week at a
time and track the number of people who
have been vaccinated remembering
that you're not considered sort of at
maximum inoculation
until seven days after dose number two
very very important to remember that
let me know where your head is on
vaccination i'm on twitter
at d pacman we'll take a quick break and
continue with more right after
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 percent off site-wide
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
that this program depends on the support
of our viewers and listeners
to exist you can grab a membership and
support the show
at joinpacman.com and get the daily
bonus show an extra show just for you
the supreme court which was held up as a
major
major major shot at uh overturning the
election
thanks to a bombshell lawsuit for donald
trump
has completely anticlimactically
rejected the case
and this has made donald trump and many
of his supporters absolutely lose their
minds now as a reminder this was a
lawsuit we discussed last week on the
bonus show
it was a lawsuit by texas backed by
donald trump
suing to throw out or block
the voting results from four different
states
now the idea was texas sued
claiming georgia michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin
were fraudulent or as trump says
fraudulent
and should be prevented from certifying
the results
which officially happens today december
14th and may already have started by the
time you listen to today's show or watch
the
the this clip the idea was get this to
the supreme court
and then donald trump's three supreme
court picks
will defiantly and heroically support
the lawsuit
and stop today's electoral vote
certification now the supreme court said
no
justices said texas doesn't have
standing to bring the case we'll talk
more about what standing means
a little bit later but this entire
bombshell lawsuit that they've been
claiming is going to just interfere and
overturn the results it's
gone in an instant with the supreme
court decision the president absolutely
lost it check this out donald trump
tweeting
that the supreme court chickened out
saying quote the fact that the supreme
court wouldn't find standing in an
original jurisdiction matter between
multiple states
and including the president of the
united states is absurd
it is enumerated in the constitution
they just
chickened out and didn't want to rule on
the merits of the case
so bad for our country now of course
what's bad for the country is a
president who clearly lost
unwilling to concede unwilling to say he
will go to the inauguration
unwilling to admit that his voter fraud
claims are not based in fact
that's bad for the country trump then
wildly tweeting in all caps this one on
for hours really even days
most corrupt election in u.s history
trump continuing to go at the supreme
court
saying that quote the supreme court had
zero interest in the merits
of the greatest voter fraud ever
perpetrated on the united states of
america
all they were interested in is quote
standing which makes it very difficult
for the president to present a case on
the merits
75 million votes now of course trump got
75 million but joe biden got way more
and won the electoral college trump's
white house press secretary
and senior campaign advisor she's both
kaylee mcinanni
appeared on fox news with sean hannity
moments after the decision on friday
and said the supreme court dodged
yeah there's no way to say it other than
they dodged
they dodged they hid behind procedure
and they refused to use their authority
to enforce the constitution
so look at how quickly number one
friends become enemies for trumpists
this is typical
of narcissists it's very very typical
you're the friend
and he's built the greatest supreme
court with his three picks and thank god
trump got to pick him instead of hillary
except now the supreme court is chicken
and the supreme court dodged so
very quickly friends become enemies when
the paradigm is narcissism uh
weaponized narcissism and number two
look at how quickly the goal posts are
moved
first it was we will overturn states
with recounts
recounts didn't work and then they said
well right the recounts recounted
fraudulent ballots so of course the
recounts are fraudulent as well
we need to throw out ballots couldn't
present any evidence every court said no
so next it went to prevent certification
by states
but state certified so it was sue
to block december 14th certification go
to the supreme court
supreme court said no now i'm there were
more intermediate steps i'm giving you
the highlights
they're irrelevant they'd always find
more steps more reasons to say
donate money to us to fight this or to
fight that
there really is no end to it the reality
is if you thought it hadn't already
ended weeks ago
we now are at the end and at the end of
the show i'll tell you about today's
electoral votes officially being cast
they won't be counted in congress until
the first week of january
presided over by mike pence that'll be a
day but we'll talk a little bit later
about what's going on today
so donald trump actually granted a
post-election interview
now that the supreme court rejected
hearing
another bogus lawsuit about so-called
voter fraud
this wasn't a real interview in the
sense that trump would be
asked actual questions and put in a
position to defend his claims with facts
it wasn't an interview in that sense it
was actually the opposite it was an
interview where donald trump was given
the repeated opportunity to make claims
not based in reality
without being challenged on anything and
the interviewer is brian kilmeade from
fox news
despite claims that fox news has gone
liberal now
by newsmax and oan brian kilmeade was
there to ensure
that no one for a second could think fox
news remains anything but a right-wing
propaganda channel
and to be clear there are countries
where if you do an interview like this
while claiming to be a reporter or
journalist
you would be publicly ostracized and you
might even have to resign from your job
because you would be so ashamed
publicly shamed for doing an interview
like this in the united states at fox
news
i guess you sort of get an atta boy for
doing an interview like this
in fact brian kilmeade helped trump
spread the lies
in this first clip brian kilmeade echoes
the lie that donald trump has previously
told which is when barack obama left
office and trump took over
the military had no ammunition they had
no bullets the
the cupboards were bare which could not
be more of a brazen lie take a look
everything you accomplished you took
over a military that was cut by 25
percent yeah
that only had three brigades ready to
fight and was out of bullets
what have you done in the four years
since you to change that
entirely rebuilt military uh like never
before
new missiles and rockets and tanks and
ships and planes and we have
the f-35s coming in by the hundreds as
you know
when i took over we had a depleted
military we had no ammunition i'll never
forget a
very overrated general coming to see me
and saying sir we have no ammunition i'm
sorry this is my first
two days in office right and i say no
president should ever have to hear that
and no president should ever be spied on
either you know
so we we set a lot of records but
we have a totally rebuilt and our
nuclear is now tippy top and just hope
to god you never have to use it
today the idea that our military was
out of bullets is so absurd that
it's hilarious if you understand the
stranglehold that the
military-industrial complex
has over our country and government and
economy including both democrats and
republicans
it's a laughable claim trump by the way
also slipping in the lie that obama
spied on his campaign which at this
point is a comedy
you know it's it's a comedy meme outside
of trump world
trump then went on to revive another
completely
bonkers notion that he previously
tweeted about which is that
listen if you need proof that i really
won this thing
election night the bookies had me
winning the election
and so clearly joe biden must have
stolen it this actually has to be seen
to be believed but
in a sense it's logical casino guy trump
says look at the bookies for proof that
this was stolen
the election was over at 10 o'clock in
the evening i had one it was 97 98
percent
all of the bookies all over the world
were saying the election's over they
wouldn't even take bets on it
and then all of a sudden around 11
o'clock ballots start getting dropped
you ever see the graph where you go like
this and then it goes up to this guy
tens of thousands of ballots were being
illegally dropped
the machines are the worst dominion
dominion nobody even knows who owns it
these machines are controlling our
country so it was a rigged election it
was a
it was really a sham and a shame when
you
at least now he's calling them massive
ballot
drops rather than massive dumps but what
he's saying
is not any more logical he lost the
election plain and simple
now this next clip is amazing because
it's the height of projection
trump says he's worried he's worried
guys
trump is worried that having an
illegitimate president would be bad for
the country
now now when trump says illegitimate
president he means joe biden but of
course
joe biden won so it's trump who would be
the illegitimate president if he
somehow figured out a way to stay in
power when you uh when you look at this
fight though
you have 77 of trump supporters who
believe you won the election according
to a fox player i've heard actually much
higher numbers
there's a there's a rally right now in
washington for that do you worry about
the country being divided as
if it goes to inauguration and they
still feel that way and you still feel
that way no i worry about the country
having an illegitimate president that's
what i worry about
a president that lost and lost badly
this wasn't like a close election
uh you look at georgia we won georgia
big we won pennsylvania big
uh we won wisconsin big we want it big
but you're going to
want all of these statements do you
think your legal team has proven that
well we don't we never get a chance to
prove it because a judge will say well
i'm sorry you don't have standing
like how about me texas and all of these
states
18 or 19 altogether they come in think
how nice that is where they actually
come in and they say we want to support
you sir because you're important to this
country we want to support you
they go in and they say the states don't
have sanding and i don't have i'm
president of the united states i just
got 75 million votes
the biggest number of votes in the
history of our country ever gotten by
sitting president
by the way let's not forget the absolute
travesty
of brian kilmeade setting up these
softball
questions for trump a true journalistic
perversion he should be ashamed of
himself
but trump continues to just be unable to
be parodied because what he says is so
ridiculous he's worried we might have an
illegitimate president yeah i am too
we just disagree about who that would be
i think the guy who won
would be the legitimate president trump
thinks the guy who won
would be illegitimate in that it's joe
biden in his mind
now this next one is interesting brian
kilmeade
actually asks trump who rigged the
election
now if we actually that that that's like
question
one point if you first ask what do you
think of the results and trump says they
were rigged against me
the first logical journalistic follow-up
is who rigged it
and how and it starts to get a little
more interesting i didn't lose
the election was rigged by who by the
democrats and actually interesting
by the democrats but by local democrats
meaning state democrats
they outsmarted state republicans you
know what i do i do two things
i run a country and we cut taxes and we
did all of the things regulations
space force so that's trump continuing
to throw the state republicans under the
bus now of course a real journalist if
brian kilmeade were one
would have had a dozen follow-up
questions based on this he didn't
but it's interesting to see trump throw
state republicans under the bus because
that's code for people
like georgia governor brian kemp who was
unwilling to do
illegal maneuvering to try to steal this
election for donald trump and that's
very
interesting because it's not praise of
brian kemp in any real way
brian remember brian kemp is a
disgusting and depraved guy
but the point is when even brian kemp is
unwilling to help a republican
it's because what trump is asking for is
that absurd
and by the way brian kemp i'm guessing
probably realizes no matter what he does
even if he were able to overturn georgia
joe biden still wins so why would he do
it
this last one is genius trump says that
they i guess meaning biden democrats his
opponents
they are winning on technicalities like
the supreme court saying texas doesn't
have standing to bring the lawsuit which
we're going to talk about in a moment no
judge has had the courage including the
supreme court i am so disappointed in
them
no judge including the supreme court of
the united states
has had the courage to allow it to be
heard the supreme court all they did is
say we don't have standing
so he they're saying essentially that
the president of the united states and
texas and these other states great
states
they don't have standing they didn't go
into the evidence if you would look at
the
evidence thousands of pages of evidence
we have over a thousand affidavits from
people
so trump again mentions affidavits which
are neither
here nor there and when we looked at the
affidavits they actually read like
comedy scripts
but the issue of standing is an
important one the supreme court did
decide
did say texas does not have standing to
challenge the results in these four
states
now in law standing means you can
demonstrate to the court
that you're connected to the harm
from the action that is being challenged
or from the law that is being challenged
and that supports you being in the case
so if i want to bring a lawsuit i have
to have some kind of standing
some connection to i'm being affected in
some way or
or whatever the case may be for texas to
have standing and suing over the results
in georgia pennsylvania whatever
you would have to say and this is i
think roughly the argument they made
well if the georgia and wisconsin and
pennsylvania if those
elections were fraudulent it essentially
devalues
the election we held in texas it makes
our election not matter it
disenfranchises texas
if other elections are fraudulent as
they claim
it's very very loose and supreme court
said no
so it's not a technicality it's it's
sort of a fundamental issue
when it comes to one's ability to bring
complaints to courts
and then absolutely last clip and then
we're going to move on
donald trump was asked given that the
supreme court did this
is it all over and trump says no we're
going to keep going
i found out late last night that the
supreme court would not hear
the texas case it did not have standing
according to them
i so judge by judging by your tweets
you're very very disappointed in that
is it over no it's not over we keep
going and we're going to continue to go
forward we have numerous local cases
where you know when
some of the states have got now what are
the next stages of keeping going
i don't know so an absolutely disgusting
interview another one in the books for
donald trump there are fewer remaining
sort of be be pleased by that at least
with trump as president
later today we'll talk about the
electoral vote certification that's
happening
and big announcement january 1st 2021
okay first day of the new year
we are going to be doing a january 1
2021 membership special the likes of
which this country has never
seen now because these these discounts
that we do
are so huge they may be illegal under a
biden administration so before biden
comes in and says no more discounts that
are this big
we are doing a january one single day
membership drive
i would really encourage you to
participate in this to be notified
just get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com very very easy get on
our newsletter
january 1 you'll get an email saying
here's how you sign up an amazing
amazing day it's going to be
and last absolutely last thing uh
follow the david pakman show on
instagram where you have
the ability to see even more clips of
the show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25 percent off your first order
it's made with four key electrolytes
that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show so
we're continuing to cover what is the
sort of emerging republican civil war
between
trumpists and non-trumpists actually
it's really trump cultists and
non-cultists because many of the people
who are not part of the cult did vote
trump but they recognized that like for
example trump lost
and it's time to move on so it's really
the cultists
versus the non-cultists and it's been
titillating and tantalizing to watch
this list of trump enemies grow and grow
and grow and the list of trump enemies
depending on who you ask
now includes fox news georgia republican
governor brian kemp and secretary of
state brad raffensberger
the supreme court is now an enemy judges
at lower courts are enemies
county commissioners and and vote
counters
the republican party itself has become
an enemy to some degree and here's just
like a little bit of insight into how
deep these delusional conspiracy
theories go
fox news is now being pulled into it
prominent trump cultist
and my pillow salesman mike lindell came
up with this one at this weekend's
million mega march
which fell a little short of a million
mega people showing up
and the claim is that fox news is not
just coincidentally bad because they
acknowledge trump lost
the claim is fox news is part of a plot
along with i guess the left and voters
to overthrow donald trump listen to this
one here is mike lindell laying it out
thank god why do you think fox declared
arizona with only 14
of the vote in they already knew what
they did they were in on it
you know i'm serious they had to be in
it you don't know this stuff
i mean all this stuff and and you know
what it's not just that
it's not just the ones behind this that
are going to end up
you know being being fought and they
should all go to prison when they are
found out
and but how about the republicans out
there
all of this stuff that's a technical
term i guess
fox news was in on all of this stuff
says mike lindell but there it is fox
news should go to prison when it's all
said and done he says
it's genuinely hilarious that now
there's a big criticism of fox news from
the right but for completely the wrong
reasons
fox news is sort of like rand paul
broken clocks eventually will get to
something that's right
and in this case it's that the daytime
fox news people are saying
trump lost but now suddenly the right is
going nuts and turning on fox news
he generally mike lindell seems
generally disconnected from reality he
also says that
the supreme court will vote nine to
nothing
on something and give the election to
trump what's gonna happen is it's gonna
be
it's so blatant everyone that i'm gonna
call my hand fraud
and i'm gonna call my foot that there
was no fraud all nine of those supreme
court justices
are going to vote 9-0 because they
here's your is that a hand or a foot
and they're going to go it's a hand
there was massive fraud
of epic proportions and
and and then it's going to unite our
country
it's going to unite our country and when
this comes out
years from now when we're going to look
back on this day
we're going to say wow god had his hands
in all this and this had to happen
in order to make the future brighter for
every single person in the united states
and the world now that's not just some
random guy
mike lindell of my pillow fame
trump actually had him at the white
house a few months ago as part of a
coronavirus briefing and he actually
spoke
and said trump is a blessing from god a
gift from god of some kind
on the previous day he said we are now
in the end times
which is usually a pretty big red flag
in my experience if someone starts
talking about the end times as something
that explains day-to-day events
you're dealing with a full-blown lunatic
and that's what mike lindell seems to be
take a look
and then all of you i want to thank
every one of you
for coming out to support this isn't our
prayer this is support
support the world is watching elections
that have to be fair in the country and
the world
because otherwise it's end times which
we're probably already in
anyway but that's a good thing that
jesus loves you all
god bless you
[Applause]
this is really a guy that i wouldn't
even trust about
pillows and he's a pillow salesman never
mind about politics
another completely out of this world
moment was when another speaker
actually promoted pillows sold by mike
lindell
i guess because my pillow is one of the
very few sponsors of this event
this is just unbelievable take a look
give him a hand clap
and a special thank you to the
co-sponsor that really helped fund
a lot of this mr mypillow himself mike
lindell
[Music]
amazing patriot loves his country loves
us loves the president and the president
loves him
and i got to tell you i love his codes
right i love his pillows i love his
sheets
i love his mattress topper and i love
his codes because you know what the
kraken has been released
you are part of the kraken so
for the best deals to support this
patriot use the code kraken
at mypillow.com we got to show him some
love he doesn't talk about a lot of the
hell that he goes through behind the
scenes friends
that i mean listen guys that coupon code
i have to admit that's an even crazier
coupon code than anything i've
i've offered i actually did not watch
any of this million maga
thing over the weekend i sort of checked
out of politics over the weekend
and i still found myself thinking about
mike lindell
not something i recommend people do but
i'm in the market for a new pillow
now by in the market i'm not it's not
i'm not really in the market i
i know exactly what pillow i want to get
i want to get
another pillow just like the one i have
and
as i was making a mental note to pull
off the pillowcase and check what kind
of a pillow i have
i thought to myself imagine if i went
and bought one of those my pillow
pillows i then immediately put it out of
my mind and ordered
the exact same pillow i already have
moved on with my day and then was
presented last night confronted last
night with videos of mike lindell
saying the supreme court will vote nine
nothing and give this election to trump
not going to happen but what might
happen is mike lindell runs
for governor i think was it minnesota
that he's thinking of running in
bizarre guy and the type of cd character
that gets front and center placement
from the current administration
but the big story here is all of these
enemies cropping up
within the republican party and trump
cultists and i want to have sort of a
bigger discussion about that next
so this is this is actually very serious
because
this could be uh this could be the start
of a ramp up
of violence by trump supporters as we
approach inauguration day for
president-elect
joe biden as i mentioned earlier there
was another one of these million mega
marches in dc this weekend
this time the trump supporters the proud
boys the white supremacists
they were actually starting to get
violent setting fires
to black lives matter banners including
at churches
getting into stabbing fights multiple
arrests we'll talk about it more on the
bonus show but what i really want to
focus on today is not that part because
we'll get to that a little bit later
but rather how this is all part of a
building republican civil war
between factions of the right you've got
the crazy right
and the really crazy right that are kind
of battling
and one of the chants that was heard
this weekend in washington dc at this
march
was destroy the gop destroy the
republican party
and the reasons that different trumpists
are mad at republicans are
numerous and wide-ranging it's actually
funny different elements of the trump
cult
are mad at the republican party or
republicans
but for different reasons that sometimes
conflict it's a comedy of errors but one
that could have real
repercussions over the next few years
and election cycles
some trumpists are mad at the republican
party because some republican officials
like brian kemp in georgia haven't been
willing to overtly
try to steal the election for donald
trump and they're furious at
brian kemp they're furious at brad
raffensberger the secretary of state in
georgia
and so on others are mad at the
republican party
because they're mad that the right-wing
supreme court justices
refused to hear a completely bogus
lawsuit
about non-existent voter fraud so some
of the ire is there
and why don't you republicans do more to
hold these people accountable apparently
not understanding
how the supreme court works other trump
cultists
are mad at fox news because they because
fox news acknowledges that joe biden won
at least during like the daytime
programming on their network
so this is interesting stuff here is a
guy
introducing another guy named nick
fuentes who's from one of these like
extra radical pro-trump wings of the
right
saying right-wingers like charlie kirk
and ben shapiro
uh essentially aren't radical enough and
and in fact
you know now i'm questioning i don't
know if nick fuentes is still
part of a pro-trump right or if they've
separated it's a complete and total mess
but listen to what was said here ben
shapiro does not believe in america
first
he started the never trump movement ben
shapiro
is a subversive
so now ben shapiro is too far left
i guess partially because ben shapiro
was anti-trump
um it's initially even though ben
shapiro voted for trump and then out
comes nick fuentes himself
and he gets to destroy the republican
party chant going
and the first million manga marks we
promised
that if the gop would not do everything
in their power to keep trump in
office then we would destroy the
and as gop gather here in washington dc
for a second million month of march
we're done making promises it has to
happen now
we are going to destroy the gop
so of course in thinking about the
future of the republican party
there's like an actual academic
discourse to be had about the future of
the two-party system
and the future of the republican party
within that and changing
demographics and how that might
influence things and gerrymandering and
redistricting
but then there's sort of like this other
uh question mark
which is if trump remains really visible
after leaving office
that will have a very different effect
on these subgroups
in the republican party than if trump
disappears from view and we won't know
that for for a few weeks
there could be a big reconciliation
among the right and all of these
elements come back together
uh it's you know this is not an
irreversible grudge that we are seeing
if trump leaves
all of these groups may quickly realize
hey what we really hate is the left
and they'll be back together in no time
on the other hand if donald trump
remains visible once he's out of office
and continues weaponizing the cultists
against other aspects of the republican
party
this could continue for some time
remember what lindsey graham
said i guess it was four or five years
ago now if we nominate trump we will get
destroyed and we will deserve it
maybe looney lindsay really was onto
something there and it would be great if
this did end up throwing the republican
party
into such chaos that they implode for a
few election cycles i do think
we should encourage it i mean why not
foment the feeling
when you're talking to traditional
republicans that these trumpists are
making them look insane
and then when you're talking to the
trumpists foment the idea that these
traditional republicans clearly
aren't committed to their movement and
they've betrayed them on this election
issue i think it's an absolutely great
idea
um but to really know what the future of
this is going to be
we have to see what happens after the
biden inauguration how visible does
trump remain and sort of go from there
i don't think we'll really know whether
the republican party is gearing up for a
sustained civil war
until it's more clear what role if any
trump will have within the republican
party
uh after january 20th so we will wait
for that
and after the break i will tell you all
about what is taking place today
to make that uh inauguration of joe
biden
an inevitable reality via the official
vote of the electoral college
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you could read 10 books in just one
sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so long
and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is a really interesting little
story
about jealousy envy double standards
probably about sexism as well it's
really about a lot of different things
and it
relates to the soon to be first lady of
the united states as many of you know
joe biden's wife is jill biden jill
biden is the incoming first lady of the
united
states jill biden has a doctorate in
education
and she's often referred to as dr jill
biden now she doesn't introduce herself
that way she doesn't say
hi oh uh uh mr
mr eggman in iowa voter yes hi i'm dr
jill biden no but she's referred to as
dr joe biden by many
now it's true that she's not a medical
doctor that is not a secret that is not
you've not
uncovered some deception uh
and the fact that she is being referred
to as dr jill biden
partially without being a medical doctor
is triggering trumpists in absolutely
hilarious fashion
and um there are regularly questions
about why is she being called
dr jill biden and recently a guy named
joseph epstein actually wrote an op-ed
in the washington uh
the wall street journal imagine actually
saying
here's something i want to weigh in on
saying dr
jill biden sounds fraudulent really only
medical doctors
should be calling themselves doctors now
the calling themselves thing is
interesting because again
other people are referring you know the
media might say or
please welcome president-elect joe biden
and
uh dr jill biden or or whatever she's
not insisting excuse me that's
dr jill biden to you but this is
actually a really old trope and
discussion this is this is not new to
jill biden
and the goal of the writer is made
even more clear by his suggestion that
instead of doctor
she be called madam first lady or mrs
biden
or jill or kiddo which of course
is increasingly patronizing as you go
through the list of names that joseph
epstein says should be applied to
jill biden now one of the reactions to
this
is this is merely sexism okay the
the the claim being if jill biden were a
man
if it was if it was uh you know dr
jeremy biden
nobody would be triggered about the use
of the term doctor
even if it was um a doctorate of
education
rather than a medical doctor i do
believe there is a degree of that for
sure
there's no doubt that this partially is
a story
because it's jill biden and not jeremy
biden or or a man
but there's actually more to this
because there are some who are saying
the issue is the term doctor
isn't relevant to the job she will be
doing as first lady
and that's why she shouldn't be referred
to as dr jill biden
well maybe but if the issue is the term
doctor
and its relevance why do we constantly
refer
to dr ben carson when we talk about
secretary of housing and urban
development and what i mean by that is
dr ben carson is a medical doctor
but he's secretary of hud a position for
which i mean
first of all a position for which he's
totally unqualified but
there's glee over referring to dr ben
carson because trump has a doctor
working for him
but being a surgeon is completely
irrelevant to housing policy so
if it's very transparent to say it's a
it's a question of relevance
i would argue having a first lady with
this high degree of education
is more relevant than a surgeon running
housing policy
that's just me though that's if they
want to play the relevance game
which to me does expose that at least
part of this is is the the gender aspect
and of course we also have so many
examples from history
of non-medical doctors dr martin luther
king jr was that
relevant i mean i think so yeah uh it
was
i don't remember if it was a doctorate
in comparative religion or
theology of some kind and he was a
reverend so yeah i mean
it certainly sounds relevant and it was
not a medical doctor
and then you know to really play this
game what about bill cosby
bill cosby also had a doctorate in
education
which she actually actually received at
my alma mater the university of
massachusetts amherst
and when some were trying to defend him
from the
numerous sexual assault claims you would
constantly hear dr cosby would never do
this
how was a doctorate in education
relevant to sex assault
so i think you see the point and for me
it's less about figuring out is it
merely sexism for me it's bigger than
that and this is there's there's a
paradigm shift coming in the white house
in terms of president and vice president
and identity
and there's a group in this country that
hates all of it they don't like that the
vice president
uh is a black asian woman they don't
like that the second gentleman is going
to be a jewish man
they don't like that there's a number of
jewish folks on biden's cabinet
and they don't like that the first lady
has a doctorate and sometimes
is referred to that is referred to
in how she is addressed and part of this
is insecurity about themselves and
education
and knowledge imagine feeling so
threatened so insecure
about the first lady having a doctorate
that you go through the trouble of
writing an op-ed suggesting she not use
it in her name
and that's really what this is about now
let's circle back
i i will never deny that people
who insist on being called doctor in
non-academic settings
is often a huge sign of pretension
whether you're a medical doctor or not i
have stories of a guy i knew with a
doctorate in sociology
who used it to sort of try to flex at
everything from restaurant reservations
yes it's it's under uh uh uh dr kester
bomb yeah
um like getting priority treatment on
flights and don't
don't you have my reservation uh i'm dr
eggman or whatever that's that's pretty
cringy
that's not what's going on here i've
never even heard jill biden
correct anyone and say that's dr jill
biden please so this is an absolute and
total joke
now we do have some good news today the
biden electoral college vote as
of this moment is underway it's december
14th
this was the day many trump has said
would be the deadline by which this
would be
completely overturned and today's votes
wouldn't happen
but electors have started casting their
votes for president around the country
there is no doubt about the winner joe
biden today will officially be the
president-elect now remember
all of these right-wingers who said the
media doesn't decide
who's president-elect well today the
electors
will decide who is president-elect and
joe biden will officially be
president-elect now
in terms of how it's all going to happen
each state
is doing this on their own schedule i
think the first date started
late morning eastern time california
doesn't vote until 5 pm eastern
and at a certain point joe biden will go
over the threshold of 270 electoral
votes
will this be the end of hearing about
these nonsense claims
and theories and bombshells that are
going to interrupt everything
from trumpists it will not the focus
today
will move i believe to january 6th
january 6th is when there is a big
session
of uh of congress where the vice
president mike pence
will be presiding over the formal
counting of these electoral votes
and we are certainly expecting
shenanigans between
now and then and also even conceivably
i mean listen if you think back to the
year 2000 the year 2000 al gore as the
vice president
had to preside over the counting
when it all came down in an election he
was in
to that recount that was stopped in
florida and there were people who stood
up and said i object to this i object to
that
i would imagine that when we have
a ignorance weaponized to the degree
that it's been weaponized over the last
four or five weeks five weeks since the
election uh we are going to see some
crazy things on december 6. we may even
see some today at
uh at the state level but uh i'm sorry
january 6th
will be a day on which we will be seeing
some really really wacky stuff
but that is today and this will be i
mean listen
we've been saying it's over for a while
uh
can we say it's extra over after today
and then after the count is done today
joe biden formally as president-elect of
the united states will be addressing the
nation reportedly around
8 pm eastern tonight i will have
coverage
live on youtube twitch and facebook
tonight starting shortly before 8pm on
the east
5pm in the west of joe biden's first
address to the nation
officially now officially as
president-elect and i do predict it'll
feel
a little bit different than it did uh
when on that saturday shortly after the
election
joe biden addressed the nation this is
certainly more official
um and we will be together starting
shortly before 8 p.m eastern tonight
see you then we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 davidp
and i have been getting many voicemails
and emails like this one this one
happens to be from the eggman
very pleased with the recent changes to
the david pakman show
call segments take a listen to this from
the eggman
hey dave in the past when you would take
phone calls that was my least
favorite part of the show but lately
i've been loving it
i love your international calls i get so
excited
i just want to say singapore and vienna
were your greatest calls this week
i'm dying laughing i love the
international calls
also your new phone system sounds great
with these uh
these callers on friday shalom brother
happy bangla all right yes shalom and
everybody celebr i call it hanukkah he
seemed to call it something else
um but uh i i have been so
anytime we do anything some people
become irate with me
but we've switched our call system from
a phone system to a web-based system
through discord at discord
davidpakman.com discord call quality in
terms of audio quality has gone up
call quality in terms of the diversity
of callers has gone up we also have the
ability to do more
screening of callers and have people
communicate what they want to ask about
if we want
i think it's been a dramatic improvement
i still have some people who are really
really mad
some who say they don't use this scored
so they can't call
discord's free you could just use it um
or not
it's also not mandatory to call in um a
couple of other complaints that now i'm
i'm
not really remembering but people
there's always a contingent that's mad
but i think it has been a dramatic
improvement and we've been hearing from
callers i mean just last week we had
singapore
we had austria we had saudi arabia or as
trump says it's saudi
um and what else we uh many callers from
latin america so that's all great stuff
and there's this whole other discussion
forum on discord as well which you can
find at davidpakman.com
slash discord on today's bonus show
california is proposing some new rules
for police officers where you either
have to be
at least 25 years old or
have a bachelor's degree the idea i
believe
is that a disproportionate number of the
bad cop complaints are some of the very
young officers
often without college degrees so if you
say the only way to be an officer
is uh if you're under 25 is to have a
bachelor's degree
you could maybe eliminate that now of
course there are arguments on the other
side that this is
unfairly removing a large swath of
possible
officers because of what may be an
economic
hardship preventing them from getting a
college degree so we're going to talk
about that
and the implications on the bonus show
we will talk about the violence and
arrests
at the trump supporter rally in
washington dc
over the weekend there was a lot of
insanity and we will also talk about
another sports team this time it's the
cleveland baseball team
which is dropping the indian nickname
after much controversy we saw washington
redskins become
i believe now they're just the
washington football team so we will talk
about that and its implications and more
get instant access to this great bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com
and remember that on january 121
1121 we will have a
huge membership special
for which you need only get on our
newsletter mailing list at
davidpakman.com
to be notified on the first day of the
new year
about this wild membership special
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant.com pacman and
use the code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman